what advice would you give to young
people today
in high school
maybe undergrad college starting out on
that journey
maybe trying to pick majors trying to
pick
jobs careers
dreams and goals they can pursue what
advice would you give them to have a
career they can be proud of or to even
have a life they can be proud of
well i think
having passion which isn't always a
voluntary thing you know you just have
it or you don't perhaps but
becoming passionate about something and
following it uh no you know wherever it
takes you i think is really important um
you know when i i finish college and
sort of went to russia for the first
time that was in some ways the beginning
of my whole career and
passions in my life
and um
i didn't know what i was going for what
was going to happen what kind of career
it would turn into what kind of job
would it help me get when i got back i
wasn't thinking about editing that i was
i'm very fortunate i got that
opportunity
i was very fortunate to you know be able
to go and see those places and have my
mind opened and i think that really just
the fuel from that
passion that was created during that
time is still 20 years later going
strong
you know i'm partial to healthcare i
love being a doctor i think it's
the perfect combination of kind of
intellectual problem solving being a
detective while also working with your
hands you know when you do procedures
especially in the er it's sort of the
perfect combination
i'm not a surgeon but i do use my hands
quite a bit
um whether you know
for a variety of reasons and so i always
loved working with my hands i loved
crafts especially prehistoric crafts
before medical school and i just love
kind of problem solving getting clues
figuring out what's going on you know
following your nose
using your instincts your knowledge and
also just keen observation of the
patient you know after seeing patient
after patient hundreds of patients maybe
thousands over years you do get this
sort of
innate kind of sense this just dalt
about what might be going on and you
know it's not always a numbers thing
that's the thing there's always
there's gestalt is actually a big part
of medicine you know you often in ers or
in hospitals hear a nurse or doctor say
something like this patient just doesn't
look good and it's sort of you can't
point to a number a value a level in
their blood you know a test
but something about them and i a lot of
that i think has to do with the color of
their skin believe it or not um which
can change and in certain disease states
but i think that uh
it's just
medicine combines this observation uh
the skills the knowledge it's art and
science it's human
and it's robotic you know algorithmic at
the same time and i think it just uh
yeah combines kind of all my passions
all in one and i would you know if
anyone's going into healthcare i'd
strongly encourage them to do so but i'm
very biased so with that early passion
whatever that little flame was that uh
brought you to russia
were you able to vocalize it or was it
just something like a gut that pulled
you towards some
exploration of the unknown or something
like this
i think it was a combination of things
one was just going to a different place
that was different from where i grew up
you know
the suburbs you know when you're in high
school you hate them later on they don't
seem so bad but you know i just wanted
to get i mean i'm very fortunate how i
was raised and
never wanted for anything that wasn't
rich but just to get out and see a
different place a different people with
a different culture and history and
language and literature and to see
different climates and geographies and
ecosystems i just wanted to see
something different
and that
i guess that's what i've you know sought
after ever since so just that was just
so fascinating like my trip to kamchatka
in 2003
where i was there for four months and um
i didn't speak english for i think two
months out of it and just i remember
lying on the floor some wooden floor in
a hunter's cabin in the middle of
northern kamchatka just being like
what am i doing here this is i'm just so
grateful for like the experiences i was
having what i was seeing and realizing
and learning it was just i was so
grateful even though i was lying on this
hard uncomfortable floor it's just like
this is so amazing
and that i don't think i'll ever have
another travel as meaningful and
life-changing as that particular trip to
kinchatka was
um
though i'm still striving after it you
know you never replicate that first high
but you always try um so
i just think that seeing something
different is kind of the game and there
wasn't really a plan because i got a
chance to talk to the ceo of qualcomm
recently
and
he
his advice is
always have a plan
and it sounds like
you're saying
don't have it don't have a plan
don't need to have a plan
just listen to your gut your passion and
follow that and see see where that takes
you because it's telling you something
yeah i think you know i guess the plan
could be specific or could be as general
as i just want to go far away and see
something very different that's my plan
and i did just one line it just followed
my nose um from one thing to the next
just being interested following my
passion and again very fortunate i could
do that
are there places in the world you're
kind of
thinking about that
your life might take you at some point
just
to be a doctor there for a time
to explore for a time
they haven't yet you know i have some
colleagues who do kind of global health
work in various countries in africa and
central and south america
i would really love to
um
go to some of those places not just for
a short trip but hopefully for an
extended period of time
um with sort of the healthcare being the
ticket in but then maybe even bringing
my children or just you know i guess at
this point
some of the travel i dream about is sort
of replicating what i did and showing it
to my kids in a way
um but there's still a lot i haven't
seen and would love to see as well but
um i think those opportunities sort of
lend themselves well
you know
as a doctor with kind of the ability to
go there and sort of help but help
patients but also teach medical students
and residents
teaching is actually a huge
part of being a doctor that's
underappreciated but that's actually
part of the fun of being a doctor is
that you're also a teacher of course the
word doctor means teacher but um it's
come to mean something else um but
you know i in some of my jobs i'm
working alongside medical students and
residents and i'm giving them my
knowledge my wisdom sharing with them
stories and so that's a very satisfying
part of the job
you